I don't want to be your fat ass okay oh
damn them fighting words I think I'm
gonna come into this negative
environment but how do you guys in a
sneak peek at the upcoming episode of
Keeping Up with the Kardashians fans get
a look at the aftermath of Kim in courts
big brawl don't ever come at me like I
saw I gotta punch you in your face so do
it
yeah you know the one my daughter's
cleaner
the epic throwdown that kicked off
season 18 with a bang
well more like a slap and a scratch it's
just so savage anyway in the upcoming
episode things seem to have calmed down
physically but emotions are still at an
all-time high and you're looking at it
so then see you at filming you're
completely fine when we're not in this
environment actually so it should both
or you or what I don't want to be yo fat
ass okay
I don't really actually the family don't
shine when my daughter's sleeping
intro court breaks down why she thinks
she hit her breaking point
I feel like they're so critical of me
every day that I'm coming in I'm like
why am i choosing to be in this
environment and I think I just like
reached my point of not being able to
tolerate it anymore
and Chloe admits that she and Kim were
shocked that things got so bad so fast I
think Kim and I both are really
surprised as to how things escalated so
quickly we don't really know where all
of this has come from we know that
there's been friction recently but I
don't think any of us knew Liz
bad and heavy
it's really surprising
that it's gone this far of course the
whole thing went down after Kim made
this comment about courts work ethic mom
is so used to me Kourtney me and Chloe
going on our new beds yeah Kourtney no
likey she straight up threw her water at
Kim calling her a choice four-letter
word and the savagery kicked off but
also if I didn't want to work my ass off
and I wanted to be a stay-at-home mom
that's been fine you think literal fans
will just have to wait till the episode
airs Thursday to see how this whole
ordeal plays out it's just tuned in
because you never know what's gonna
happen but according to court
she's officially done with the show
after the big fight episode aired the 40
year old got called out on Twitter by a
fan who wrote Kourtney Kardashian just
needs to quit the damn show I'm over her
not wanting to film court's response I
did bye
and Mike job when et caught up with
Kourtney in October she weighed in on
all those rumors that she was ready to
quit keeping up you mentioned that you
might be ready to say goodbye to Keeping
Up with the Kardashians where are you at
on that um I'm just decided to spend
more time as a mom and you know put more
of my energy there and still but I'm not
saying goodbye do you think the show can
continue going if you lose a sister we
definitely love Kourtney and we will
miss Courtney and whatever she decides
to do but people come people go all the
time this family we feel like at the
revolving door so Kourtney might leave
this week she'll be back they all come
back
and on Tuesday Kim had this to say about
her big sis during a chat with Jimmy
Fallon on The Tonight Show and I don't
really ever resort to violence like that
but she scratched me so hard
when I looked down at my arm and I saw
like she had really scratched me and I
felt it all on my back I just you know
went over and slapped her back so it's
not like my proud
moment but we were going through it and
she's made the decision to take time off
now and I think she really needs it and
I think that'll be so much better for
her
[Music]